uh eight houses here we're in vision now
let's just take it really slowly jake
because they keep losing it there's
about eight houses here that have been
flattened utterly flattened there were
about six people from one family
who died here three of them were
children one of about 12 years old the
other one i think was also an older
teenager
unbelievably a couple of civilians
survived the people that we've been
talking to who are picking through the
rubble and you've got to remember this
is an entirely residential area it's
filled with farm houses
and homes
they say that they're now
reduced to trying to find just any
documents or any um bits of possessions
for the one of the men who managed to
survive one of the men of the family who
managed to survive there were two two of
the grandchildren were staying in that
partially um standing building there who
also managed to survive
but look at what these bombs have done
and they they the people who were around
the village spoke of hearing three
really loud explosions as as bombs were
dropped and the they they're obviously
now utterly terrified they this happened
a couple of days ago on friday um
they're still reeling from the shock of
it all and i think it follows a pattern
of an increasing number of civilians and
civilian targets or civilian locations
which appear to be um targeted or
certainly not
um off the agenda of the the the russian
war machine
here they i told you they're trying to
pick through the remnants of whatever's
left here just to find official
documents and um anything that um
that the family that the family members
who've survived can grasp onto and a
number of these are um i think this this
gentleman is a is a relative um we spoke
to them earlier they they only speak uh
ukrainian but they were saying about how
they've spent the past couple of days
just sifting through
all of this
um and trying to make sense of what
happened there
they're pretty much in shock to be
honest and very concerned about the in
the increasing
what they see and perceive as increasing
attacks
the woman that you see there who's been
going through
all the rubble um had some pretty choice
words for the um the russian president
um
when
i asked her about what what she she
thought about was happening in this area
and we know that yesterday we were in a
completely different area where um
civilians who were trying to flee an
active combat zone were being fired on
as they were trying to flee
so there is no civilian at the moment in
in ukraine who feels particularly safe
at the moment there are no international
laws it seems which are being observed
and a lot of anger and hesitation
earlier we were talking to the former
ukrainian president petra polish
poroshenko who was
on the one hand saying how grateful he
was
to britain america a number of other
countries um in the west who've rallied
to ukraine's support but also demanding
so much more
urging so much more action saying that
he he was incredibly bullish about the
prospects of ukraine
actually succeeding in this um david and
goliath battle you know because the
ukrainian military is pretty much
dwarfed by the russian one and
the numbers of of russian soldiers but
he feels that they have the courage the
determination the defiance however
he says they need
so much more they need
aircraft they need the fly the skies to
be closed he's demanding he they want
more weapons they want
much more unified response basically
from the international community and he
had some fairly cautionary and chilling
words about how this you know this isn't
just ukraine's fight this is the whole
world fight he believes it's a real
um defense
of democracy and freedom and he felt
like uh
the reticence of the rest of the world
not to get involved he felt was almost
foolhardy because sooner or later he
said they are going to get involved the
rest of the world is going to get
involved unless
the russian leader is stopped but this
this is a
scene of utter utter and complete
devastation and
nowhere have we seen anything that even
comes close to a military target